authorities in ukraine's port city of
mariupol say they've agreed another
temporary ceasefire with russian forces
and are renewing efforts to evacuate
some of the 400 000 civilians trapped
there
attempts to get residents out of
mariupol in another city besieged by
moscow's troops in southeastern ukraine
were called off on saturday both sides
accused the other of violating a
temporary truce russian forces resumed
their attacks against several key cities
dw's matthias bulinger is in kiev forest
matthias uh a second attempt today at
humanitarian ceasefire to allow for
evacuations now there are reports that
people have already started to leave is
the ceasefire more likely to hold today
than yesterday
we don't have a clear picture yet it
seems that people have started to leave
but this is to be yet to be confirmed
buses have left this morning for the uh
for mario paul and so far we are not
hearing anything that suggests that the
ceasefire has been violated so far so
there's hope that this is going to work
uh we'll know when it's done i think
everything is a little bit fragile at
the moment and uh
we don't even know exactly how this
yesterday happened what happened exactly
so the ceasefire was broken so um
uh carefully optimistic that this time
some people will get out but we need
confirmation
now you're in kiev what's the situation
there in the capital and surrounds
you can see that the streets are almost
empty here in the capital um there and
people are still careful many have also
left the city so kiev resembles a lot uh
has a lot of uh
resemblance to a ghost town right now
people uh who have not left are
basically staying at home a lot um
in the outskirts we are hearing of
severe fights again um we have also
heard news that some civilians trying to
flee the most
contested
suburbs that places where fighting has
been taking place for days where the
humanitarian situation is really dire
and uh where people have been sitting in
the shelters for days that
people trying to flee these areas have
been shelled and there was supposed to
be a humanitarian corridor there as well
it has not happened yet
uh vladimir putin warned yesterday that
western sanctions are basically a
declaration of war is that is this then
the prelude for the next level of
escalation
nobody dodges vladimir putin's warnings
anymore after this i think everything
every threat he makes has to be taken
serious however the russian army is
engaged now in ukraine and it's doing
much worse than uh putin himself might
have anticipated and also many observers
so this might not be imminent but
the the countries that are on his menu
that he has appetite for there is are
quite a few and uh of course uh this
might also mean at some point that he
might engage with countries that are uh
part of nato this is not imminent as
long as things go the way they are now
in ukraine but uh
there's no need to
to to to dodge putin's warnings
what about matthias the the infamous
stalled convoy are there any signs of
that getting up and running and what
would that mean
again please which convoy
that infamous convoy that's now stalled
it's sick the 60 kilometer convoy that
stalled outside of kiev
yeah yeah i see i see um yeah
it has been standing there for days and
it has not moving the best guess is that
some some technology there is broken or
they have they don't have supply uh to
to move this convoy it seems to be
rather a case of uh bad planning um by
the russian army than uh an imminent
threat but of course all everything we
are hearing saying and and
we think we know is is to be seen with
caution uh the situation is very hard to
it's everything is very hard to verify
but uh the best guess at the moment is
that this was never meant to be a huge
convoy but that these cars are stuck on
the road and that this car this is
rather a traffic jam that cannot be
resolved than an attacking convoy
dw's matthias birlinger in key for us
matthias thank you
you